[Música]
como fraudulentas catalogaron las
elecciones de nicaragua varios
legisladores de américa latina estados
unidos y europa desde ya rechazaron los
resultados del próximo 7 de noviembre y
la corte interamericana de derechos
humanos pidió la liberación de los
candidatos opositores que están
encarcelados la cámara de representantes
de estados unidos pospuso la votación
sobre el plan de gasto social del
presidente joe biden que contempla más
de 18 billones de dólares sin embargo
los demócratas esperan que hoy avance el
plan de infraestructura en momentos en
los que el mandatario atraviesa caídas
en su aceptación
y la juventud está perdiendo la
esperanza frente a los mandatarios y su
lucha contra la emergencia climática el
movimiento friday's vercher exige
acciones concretas y su lideresa la
activista creta schönberg calificó la
cumbre como un fracaso
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
yo soy maría clara calle y los
acompañaré en este recorrido y
comenzamos con noticias latinoamericanas
en nicaragua cerraron hoy las campañas
presidenciales de cara a los comicios
del domingo 7 de noviembre pero hay
duras críticas por las decenas de
opositores detenidos legisladores de
américa latina estados unidos y europa
consideraron que los comicios son
fraudulentos y rechazan desde ya los
resultados la corte interamericana de
derechos humanos exigió la liberación de
14 opositores incluida cristiana
chamorro la figura más fuerte que se
enfrentaría al presidente daniel ortega
hablamos previamente con la ex
presidenta de costa rica laura
chinchilla sobre el papel de la
comunidad internacional en estos
comicios
miren por lo menos también me parece más
allá de que se pueda garantizar
resultados efectivos
después del 7 de noviembre a mí sí me
parece que al menos la comunidad
internacional no puede esperar a que
llegue el 7 y el día al día siguiente
preguntarse y ahora qué es lo que sigue
es el y ese sería el peor mensaje que
estarían recibiendo los autócratas del
mundo que como en el caso de daniel han
venido desafiando día a día a plena luz
del día los distintos llamados y
resoluciones que se han emitido en el
seno al consejo de derechos humanos se
hicieron la asamblea general o el
consejo permanente de la oea pero además
las consecuencias de lo que daniel ha
estado haciendo para ser muy graves
sobre la estabilidad política de
centroamérica sobre todo el hemisferio
en materia humanitaria y con graves
secuelas desde el punto de vista
democrático de ahí que si la comunidad
internacional tiene todavía mucho margen
de maniobra
mediante la imposición de sanciones
individuales y económicas y como también
mediante una estrategia diplomática
concertada y consistente vayamos a eeuu
porque la cámara de representantes-
pospuso el voto del plan de gasto social
del presidente joe biden previsto para
hoy el proyecto propone 1,8 billones de
dólares para medidas ambientales y
sociales la presidenta de la cámara baja
nancy pelosi asegura que esperan aprobar
hoy el plan de infraestructura de 1,2
billones y que la agenda completa puede
ser aprobada para el día de acción de
gracias escuchemos lo que dijo
hemos esperado bastante y esperábamos
aprobarla antes pero no podemos esperar
mucho más por la legislación
yo sí creo que hay un gran número de
miembros de caucus progresista que
votarán para aprobar este proyecto de
ley
y en la cumbre climática cop 26 los
jóvenes hoy fueron los protagonistas
pero ellos son escépticos en las
jornadas y discutió cómo aprovechar la
conciencia ecológica de las nuevas
generaciones para resolver la crisis
climática además el movimiento friday's
for future marchó en las calles de
glasgow para pedirle una vez más
acciones reales a los mandatarios del
mundo la activista sueca greta schönberg
calificó la cumbre como un fracaso y
como otro evento de relaciones públicas
no es un secreto que la cob 26 es un
fracaso debería ser obvio que no podemos
resolver esta crisis con los mismos
métodos que nos metieron en ella en
primer lugar
en noticias de áfrica del consejo de
seguridad de la onu pidió que se acaben
los combates en etiopía también sugirió
comenzar unas conversaciones sobre un
alto al fuego de las partes que llevan
casi un año en conflicto sin embargo es
poco probable que sancionen al país pues
rusia y china- que son dos de los cinco
miembros permanentes del consejo de
seguridad han dicho que el conflicto es
un asunto interno de etiopía veamos en
qué van los enfrentamientos
es una ceremonia perfectamente
organizada delante de miles de
seguidores reunidos en un estadio de
addis abeba la alcaldesa de la capital
pasa revista a los nuevos reclutas
militares en unos días estos hombres
irán al frente para intentar frenar el
avance de los rebeldes hacia la ciudad
ya la vez
organicémonos todos estemos todos
preparados ciudadanos policía y fuerzas
armadas trabajan día y noche olvidemos
al cansancio no tenemos derecho a estar
cansados en este momento crítico
[Música]
es una ciudad en pie de guerra el avance
relámpago de los rebeldes tomó por
sorpresa al gobierno tras haber
controlado el tigre el mes de junio
acaban de hacerse con dos ciudades
estratégicas en la región de amhara el
miércoles se encontraban a 300
kilómetros de la capital donde se les
unieron combatientes del ejército de
liberación oromo otra facción rebelde
ahora el gobierno llama a sus
partidarios a frenar el avance de los
que califican como terroristas choco
etiopía no se derrumbara el que
prosperará etiopía existirá para siempre
el parlamento ha declarado el estado de
emergencia en todo el país desde hace un
año el conflicto entre el gobierno y los
rebeldes ha dado un giro espectacular
con la retirada forzada del ejército
etíope
a raíz de este conflicto la suerte de
los civiles de la región preocupa mucho
a la comunidad internacional según la
onu más de 400.000 personas están al
borde de la hambruna la alta comisionada
de la onu para los derechos humanos
michelle bachelet le pidió a los líderes
militares de sudán que se retiren luego
del golpe de estado que propinaron la
semana pasada en la sesión de emergencia
del consejo de derechos humanos de la
onu para debatir sobre sudán bachelet
pidió también que las fuerzas armadas no
ataquen más a la población civil y es
que ya se han reportado por lo menos 13
civiles muertos desde el golpe militar
urjo a los líderes militares de
ciudadanía quienes los apoyan a que
retrocedan para permitir que el país
regrese al camino del progreso hacia las
reformas institucionales y legales en
particular los últimos dos años han
tenido un progreso valioso hacia el
establecimiento de la comisión nacional
de derechos humanos y comisiones
independientes claves previstas en el
documento constitucional incluyendo
justicia transicional tierra mujeres y
equidad de género reformas legales y
corrupción arts inc
vayamos ahora hasta medio oriente
afganistán está a un paso de convertirse
en la peor crisis humanitaria de todo el
mundo según la onu casi la mitad de la
población se enfrenta a una inseguridad
alimentaria aguda a partir de este mes
de noviembre así lo afirmó el programa
mundial de alimentos de naciones unidas
que además advierte que 32 millones de
niños afganos están amenazados por la
malnutrición severa la situación empeora
con el invierno que se aproxima veamos
más en este siguiente informe
kabul como el resto del país se está
hundiendo en la pobreza en este
campamento improvisado cuatro niños
murieron de inanición la semana pasada
la escasa distribución de alimentos por
parte de voluntarios a menudo termina en
violencia
las familias con hombres pueden ir y
conseguir comida pero las familias de
mujeres como la mía no podemos luchar
así que pasamos hambre hace tres meses
cerca de 200 familias desplazadas por el
conflicto encontraron refugio en este
terreno baldío desde entonces han estado
luchando para alimentarse
tuvimos tres vasos de arroz hervido para
el almuerzo hoy eso es todo
ayer solo tuvimos pan con té algunos
días apenas tenemos eso y otros días la
gente nos da un kilo de arroz aquí ayer
esta mañana mi hijo me pidió dinero para
comprar algo de pan porque tenía hambre
le dije que esperara hasta que llegara
mi esposo tenía demasiada hambre para
esperar así que le pedía a nuestros
vecinos de la carpa de al lado cuando
llegó mi esposo no tenía dinero así que
no comimos casi un tercio de la
población ya está enfrentando
inseguridad alimentaria en los mercados
los puestos todavía están surtidos pero
los clientes son escasos la crisis
económica junto con la sequía del
invierno han impulsado al alza de los
precios
de las papas que acabo de comprar son
muy costosas los precios han subido el
doble todo está aumentando y trabajo
para nosotros
desde que los talibanes se apoderaron
del país la ayuda internacional para el
desarrollo ha quedado bloqueada el nuevo
gobierno inició un programa llamado
comida por trabajo en las ciudades más
grandes del país incluyendo kabul a
cambio de trabajo en nuestra
municipalidad repartirá kilos de trigo
este invierno a los hombres capaces de
hacer trabajo físico
hemos identificado de 2.500 a 3.000
personas en kabul con la nieve y la
lluvia tan cerca los sistemas de desagüe
van a necesitar mucho mantenimiento
según la onu 9 de cada 10 familias
afganas no tendrán suficiente comida en
los meses por venir una crisis
alimentaria que solo hay en noticias de
la pandemia la píldora contra el cob y
19 de la farmacéutica pfiezer es un 89
por ciento efectiva para evitar casos de
hospitalización o muerte así lo informó
la propia compañía que solicitará la
autorización para su uso a las entidades
regulatorias de eeuu se trata de la
segunda píldora de este tipo tras la que
anunció la farmacéutica merck el pasado
primero de octubre rodrigo se da no nos
explica una nueva esperanza en la lucha
por controlar la pandemia la
farmacéutica estadounidense pfizer
anunció los resultados sobre la
efectividad de una nueva pastilla
antiviral contra el coronavirus bajo el
nombre de pax lobby
nos enorgullece anunciar que según
nuevos datos nuestro candidato a
antiviral oral contra el kobe 19
demostró reducir significativamente el
riesgo de muerte u hospitalización en
adultos de alto riesgo según fischer el
fármaco está diseñado para bloquear una
enzima que el coronavirus necesita para
hacer copias de sí mismo de este modo se
evita que invada al infectado con esta
tecnología se conseguiría una reducción
del 89% en la tasa de hospitalización y
muertes de pacientes infectados por kobe
la altísima eficacia nos sorprende
incluso a nosotros supera las
expectativas más visionarias que
teníamos al respecto
ahora nos lanzaremos de inmediato a ver
qué más podemos hacer en la fabricación
de suministro en el estudio participaron
mil 219 personas de ellos 775 tomaron la
píldora la farmacéutica estima que
podría producir 180.000 paquetes del
fármaco para finales de este año la
cifra ascendería a 50 millones en 2022
el presidente de estados unidos joe
biden se pronunció sobre la noticia
ya hemos asegurado millones de dosis y
la terapia sería una herramienta más
para proteger a la gente de los peores
resultados del hobbit ambos anuncios
llegan un día después de que reino unido
aprobara el uso de una píldora similar
desarrollada por la farmacéutica merck
sin embargo este fármaco destinado
principalmente a personas con factores
de riesgo presenta solamente una
efectividad del 50 por ciento hablemos
de francia porque al menos un año de
casa por cárcel deberá pagar el ex
asesor de seguridad del presidente
francés emmanuel mayor alexandre ven a
la aunque fue sentenciado hoy a tres
años de cárcel dos de ellos están
suspendidos ven a la fue hallado
responsable por agredir a manifestantes
durante las movilizaciones de 2018 y
también por usar pasaportes diplomáticos
ilegales y portar un arma sin permiso el
ex asesor de seguridad protagonizó el
primer gran escándalo de la
administración de manuel bajo
y desviar un asteroide para ensayar cómo
proteger a la tierra de un hipotético
impacto este es el nuevo proyecto de la
nasa pero como pretenden hacerlo pues
quieren chocar una nave espacial contra
una gigantesca roca espacial aquí les
contamos la historia
la prueba para redireccionar un doble
asteroide a una misión para proteger el
planeta en caso de que un asteroide se
dirija a la tierra
y que parece una recreación de la
superproducción de hollywood armageddon
el 29 de noviembre la nasa lanzará una
nave especial tarde con un claro
objetivo determinar si los humanos son
capaces de alterar la trayectoria de un
asteroide
[Música]
aquí hay dos asteroides esta vivimos el
más grande que tiene 780 metros de
diámetro y un pequeño asteroide lunar
que lo rodea que se llama dy morphos así
que lo que dart va a hacer es ir a toda
velocidad más de 24.000 kilómetros por
hora y va a apuntar a dee morphos el más
pequeño de esos dos asteroides de este
asteroide por separado otra nave grabará
la colisión y aunque de morphos no
supone una amenaza para nuestro planeta
la agencia espacial dice que les ha
regalado una oportunidad perfecta
esto es una prueba no queremos estar en
la situación en la que un asteroide se
dirija hacia la tierra y tener que
probar este tipo de capacidad queremos
saber cómo funciona la nave y cuál será
la reacción del asteroide ante el
impacto antes de llegar a una situación
así
se espera a quedar colisione con de
morphos dentro de un año aproximadamente
y esta es sólo la primera de muchas
pruebas de ciencia ficción que están por
venir ya que la nasa también quiere
probar otras estrategias como disparar a
un asteroide con un láser
y con estas imágenes de la nasa nos
despedimos pero sigan conectados ustedes
a la señal de france 24 y esperen las
noticias de mi compañera valentina torre
sánchez
[Música]